their withdrawal of the Commissioner
designate energy Union and lenka beretta
Scheck led to reshuffle and new hearings
slovakia's Maris if kuvira's bumped up
from transport winning a vice-president
seat and in his place
Violetta boots with the Parliament
needing to sign off on Yonkers dream
team by Wednesday for MEP is ready to
get behind the Slovenian businesswoman
those who said already we have to vote
for her because otherwise on Wednesday
will be fair will fail that is not
correct if that is the case then we can
stop having hearings and the spotlight
boot set out her vision if I had to sum
up my future agenda to you in one word
it would be people we will need what I
would call a technology push funded by
public and private investment involving
as many parts of the transport sector as
possible and key sound bites support for
better connected Europe I will continue
to support optimal connectivity across
Europe in an integrated conceptual
system this is why it is so crucial to
turn the trans-european transport
network into a reality
but even if ambition really became
reality with future funding be enough
what would be your reaction in let's say
an end of 2016 when it won't be clear
said some of the connecting Europe
facility Corridor projects related with
the cohesion fund countries will not
have any progress at all on member state
level we are facing for some reason the
import and critical projects that are on
a critical path just are not implemented
so how can we hope for better Europe if
we don't get the vital projects finished
if they are not finished so that's why I
find this concept use it or lose it a
good one because it stimulates so
despite the few days preparation bolts
was putting on a decent show but for
some questions over the new Commission's
commitment the transport portfolio
Bellavia register module officio
Commission European Lee transported a
Cerritos area Kimmi reduced as reduces
musical c'est la vie au coccidia the
situation so well Violetta bolts be able
to go home and sleep well in the
knowledge shall be confirmed we'll have
to wait and see